well when an emotional prime minister
unveiled the wording of the question
that will go to the Australian people
later this year flanked by members of
the indigenous community on Thursday
those words were tabled in the nation's
Parliament history I trust the
Australian people to understand that
this is an opportunity for a better
future not just for the First Peoples of
Australia but for all Australians
if Australia votes yes in the proposed
referendum Not only would the
Constitution be amended to recognize the
First Nations people for the first time
it would also enshrine an advisory body
to Parliament made up of Aboriginal and
Torres Strait Islanders to guide federal
policy but some lawmakers say the voice
is symbolic only and Australians should
vote no black people in this country
being calling out governments for 200
years on what they can be doing better
for us and we still have no justice and
I don't see the voice
um giving us Justice Senator Thorpe is
one of 11 parliamentarians who identify
as indigenous Australians in the
nation's Federal Parliament Australia's
Aboriginal population makes up three
percent of the nearly 26 million people
critics say issues like racism and
Aboriginal deaths in custody needs to be
prioritized we have
black bodies
um
dying at the hands of the system and we
have solutions to
um
this catastrophe crisis that's been
going on against First Nations people
for far too long uh that this government
and the previous government just are not
interested in implementing
constitutional lawyers remain divided on
whether this could lead to government
decisions being challenged in the
nation's High Court
it's possible there will be high court
matters arising out of this but you'd
have to say that's entirely normal we
are looking at putting words into the
Constitution the high Court's job is to
interpret the Constitution this is the
random to be
eight have been successful the Prime
Minister says this legislation provides
a once in a generation chance to rectify
the past
referendum is expected to be held in
October this year
Sarah Clark Al Jazeera